After a long day, trust me there's no reason
that you can't make dinner at home.
That's why today I'm putting the challenge
out there to see, if Mia can do in just under 10 minutes.
Welcome, to Ramsay in 10.
Hi, I'm chef Mia Castro, and chef Ramsay challenged me
today to make a pasta dish under 10 minutes.
and I'm making an all-time college favourite ramen
Cacio e Pepe
It's pasta with Cacio - cheese, pepe - pepper,
And, I'm using ramen because it cooks within 2 - 3 minutes
And you probably have it in your pantry anyways already.
So, let's start the clock and lets get started.
This is some, fresh ramen.
If you don't have fresh ramen, which you can find
in the refrigerated section
at, like your organic grocery store.
You can just use, your traditional, Uhm, your traditional package ramen.
They both cook in under 10 minutes.
The fresh one cooks in 2 - 3 because it's fresh.
And the one in the package cooks in about the same time
So all these ingredients are staples in my kitchen,
so it's really easy for me to make when I've came home from a busy day at work
or when it's really cold outside
and I want something hearty.
In here, I have a preheated pan.
Just a little too hot, so I'm gonna let it cool down
and I'm gonna put some olive oil, some butter
They have Gordon's fancy Peppermill here
if you don't have this at home, they sell them at the grocery store
the disposable kind, either one works the same,
you're gonna get the same quality meal.
And I like to do the pepper straight into the butter,
Cuz it gets it really aromatic.
This is another one of those dishes where you don't have to measure everything,
you kind of want to do everything by tasting
so it depends on how spicy you like it,
how much pepper you're gonna add.
I'm putting all the directions below anyway
just in case you need it,
but it should be pretty easy for you to make.
I'm just gonna test one of these noodles.
Great.
So I'm gonna go straight into the pan with the noodles
And it's actually good if you get some of that pasta water in there.
Because it will help you make a sauce with the starch
Bring it onto the pan.
Stir it around
and I'm gonna add a little bit of that pasta water in here
and what that does is it makes a really nice sauce
When you combine it with the cheese
This is fresh grated Pecorino,
you can use Parmesan as well,
but I prefer the sharpness of the Pecorino.
Few handfuls.
Move it around.
And you can see there how the sauce is starting
to form.
Pasta is one of my favorite things to eat,
but I don't always have time or I don't always really want to cook
so I like using ramen in place of pasta in a lot of dishes
and I actually lived off of it in college
and I would make all sorts of different things.
Spaghetti, the Cacio e Pepe, carbonara, you can use it anything.
Go with a little bit more water.
And the beauty of ramen noodles is that
it cooks a lot faster than regular pasta
and it's cheap. So you don't have to go
to a restaurant to get this dish.
I'm gonna go ahead and taste it.
A little bit more salt.
So you need to be a little more careful when you're using the traditional packaged ramen
because they cook faster so you probably want to cook them a little less when they're in the water.
and as soon as they get really nice and creamy
and you get a really nice tight sauce like that.
They're ready to serve.
I have plenty of time to make this look great right now.
So you want to get fancy you just give it that nice swirl on top with the tongs.
Give it a little height. Picture-perfect.
and then just finish it off with a sprinkling of Pecorino
and some fresh cracked pepper.
This is a dish that you can make in
well under 10 minutes
So there's no excuse for you not to make this at home
So, boom.
Ramen Cacio e Pepe, Gordon.
Under 10 minutes and under $10.
Leave a comment below on what you think of this dish
and don't forget to subscribe to
Gordon's YouTube channel.
See you next time.
Oh my god when I was in ramen
Sorry *laughs*